welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Ahsoka season 1 he has an apprentice
evil bangs girl saine's out of practice
and she gets stabbed but don't worry
she's fine who needs a spleen anyway hey
we never met who are you what's your
deal I mean the Star Wars Galaxy isn't
that big relatively s of being an evil
bangs have their rematch luckily C3PO
shows up to shut this guy down yeah
these space squid whales are maybe super
cute or maybe Elder chores as a bean has
round three with her rival evil bangs so
thr's backup plan he sends more Storm
Troopers at him but two and a half Jedi
can take down and infinite number of
Stormtroopers butron had a Backup backup
plan but thron has a triple backup plan
butron still has one backup plan left
evil bangs is still out there hey what's
up I guess I'm Your Leader now Force
ghost hakin Skywalker yeah he made it to
Ghostville